- [Voiceover] Hey guys.
There's one more thing
I need to talk about
before I can describe the vectorized form
for the quadratic approximation
of multivariable functions
which is a mouthful to say
so let's say you have
some kind of expression
that looks like a times x squared
and I'm thinking x is a variable
times b times xy,
y is another variable,
plus c times y squared
and I'm thinking of a, b
and c as being constants
and x and y as being variables.
Now, this kind of
expression has a fancy name.
It's called a quadratic form.
Quadratic
form.
And that always threw me off.
I always kind of was like, what,
what does form mean?
I know what a quadratic expression is
and quadratic typically
means something is squared
or you have two variables
but why do they call it a form?
And basically it just means
that the only things in here
are quadratic.
It's not the case that you have an x term
sitting on its own or a constant out here
like two when you're adding
all of those together
instead it's just you have
purely quadratic terms
but of course, mathematicians
don't want to call it
just a purely quadratic expression
instead they have to give
a fancy name to things
so that it seems more
intimidating than it needs to be
but anyways, so we have a quadratic form
and the question is
how can we express this
in a vectorized sense?
And for analogy, let's
think about linear terms
where let's say you have a times x
plus b times y
and I'll throw another variable in there,
another constant times another variable z.
If you see something like this
where every variable is just
being multiplied by a constant
and then you add terms
like that to each other,
we can express this nicely with vectors
where you pile all of the
constants into their own vector,
a vector containing a, b and c
and you imagine the dot product
between that and a vector that contains
all of the variable components,
x, y and z
and the convenience here is
then you can have just a symbol
like a v let's say
which represents this
whole constant vector
and then you can write down,
take the dot product between that
and then have another symbol,
maybe a bold faced x
which represents a vector that
contains all of the variables
and this way, your notation
just kind of looks like
a constant times a variable
just like in the single variable world
when you have a constant
number times a variable number,
it's kind of like taking a constant vector
times a variable vector.
And the importance of
writing things down like this
is that v could be a vector
that contains not just three numbers
but a hundred numbers
and then x would have a
hundred corresponding variables
and the notation doesn't
become any more complicated.
It's generalizable at
the higher dimensions.
So the question is
can be we do something similar like that
with our quadratic form?
Because you can imagine
let's say we started
introducing the variable z
then you would have to
have some other term,
some other constant times
the xz quadratic term
and then some other constant
times the z squared quadratic term
and another one for the yz quadratic term
and it would get out of hand
and as soon as you
start introducing things
like a hundred variables,
it would get seriously out of hand
because there's a lot of
different quadratic terms
so we want a nice way to express this.
And I'm just going to kind
of show you how we do it
and then we'll work it through
to see why it makes sense.
So usually, instead of
thinking of b times xy,
we actually think of this
as two times some constant
times xy
and this of course
doesn't make a difference.
You would just change what b represents
but you'll see why it's more
convenient to write it this way
in just a moment.
So the vectorized way to describe
a quadratic form like this
is to take a matrix,
a two by two matrix since
this is two dimensions
where a and c are in the diagonal
and then b is on the other diagonal
and we always think of these
as being symmetric matrices
so if you imagine kind of
reflecting the whole matrix
about this line,
you'll get the same number
so it's important that we
have that kind of symmetry.
And now what you do is
you multiply the vector,
the variable vector that's got x, y
on the right side of this matrix
and then you multiply it again
but you turn it on its side
so instead of being a vertical vector,
you transpose it to
being a horizontal vector
on the other side.
And this is a little bit analogous too
having two variables multiplied in.
You have two vectors multiplied
in but on either side.
And this is a good point by the way
if you are uncomfortable
with matrix multiplication
to maybe pause the video,
go find the videos about
matrix multiplication
and kind of refresh or learn about that
because moving forward,
I'm just going to assume
that it's something you're familiar with.
So going about computing this,
first, let's tackle this
right multiplication here.
We have a matrix multiplied by a vector.
Well, the first component that we get,
we're going to multiply the top row
by each corresponding term in the vector
so it'll be a times x.
a times x
plus b times y.
Plus b times that second term y
and then similarly for the bottom term,
we'll take the bottom row
and multiply the corresponding terms
so b times x.
b times x
plus c times y.
c times y.
So that's what it looks like
when we do that right multiplication
and of course we've got to
keep our transposed vector
over there on the right,
on the left side.
So now, we have,
this is just a two by one vector now
and this is a one by two.
You could think of it
as a horizontal vector
or a one by two matrix
but now when we multiply these guys,
you just kind of line up
the corresponding terms.
You'll have x multiplied by
that entire top expression
so x multiplied by ax plus by.
ax plus by
and then we add that to the second term y
multiplied by the second term of this guy
which is bx plus cy
so y multiplied by
bx plus cy
and all of these are numbers
so we can simplify it
once we start distributing the first term
is x times a times x
so that's ax squared
and then the next term
is x times b times y
so that's b times xy.
Over here, we have y times b times x
so that's the same thing as b times xy
so that's kind of why we have,
why it's convenient to write a two there
because that naturally
comes out of our expansion.
And then the last term
is y times c times y
so that's cy squared.
So we get back the original quadratic form
that we were shooting for.
ax squared plus two bxy plus cy squared
That's how this entire term expands.
As you kind of work it through,
you end up with the same
quadratic expression.
Now, the convenience
of this quadratic form
being written with a matrix like this
is that we can write
this more abstractally
and instead of writing
the whole matrix in,
you could just let a letter like m
represent that whole matrix
and then take the vector
that represents the variable,
maybe a bold faced x
and you would multiply it on the right
and then you transpose it
and multiply it on the left
so typically you denote that
by putting a little t as a superscript
so x transposed multiplied by
the matrix from the left
and this expression,
this is what a quadratic form
looks like in vectorized form
and the convenience is the same
as it was in the linear case.
Just like v could represent
something that had a hundred
different numbers in it
and x would have a hundred
different constants,
you could do something similar here
where you can write that same expression
even if the matrix m is super huge.
Let's just see what this would look like
in a three dimensional circumstance so,
actually, I'll need more room
so I'll go down even further.
So we have x transpose
multiplied by the matrix
multiplied by x, bold faced x
and let's say instead this represented,
you have x then y then z,
our transposed vector
and then our matrix,
our matrix let's say was a, b, c,
d, e, f and because it
needs to be symmetric,
whatever term is in this spot here
needs to be the same as over here
kind of when you reflect
it about that diagonal.
Similarly, c, that's going
to be the same term here
and e would be over here.
So there's only really six
free terms that you have
but if fills up this entire matrix
and then on the right side,
we would multiply that by
x, y, z.
Now, I won't work it out in this video
but you can imagine actually
multiplying this matrix
by this vector
and then multiplying the
corresponding vector that you get
by this transposed vector
and you'll get some kind of quadratic form
with three variables
and the point is you'll
get a very complicated one
but it's very simple to
express things like this.
So with that tool in hand,
in the next video,
I will talk about how
we can use this notation
to express the quadratic approximations
for multivariable functions.
See you then.